si vous ne connaissez pas lens piot
rassurez vous elle de son côté vous
connais sûrement plus fort que la dgs si
laurence à des dossiers sur tout et sur
tout le monde pourquoi et bien parce
qu'elle a été durant 14 ans la
directrice de la rédaction du magazine
closer un magazine qu'elle a en partie
créé sous sa direction les scoops les
plus sulfureux de ces dernières années
parmi eux un véritable de mettre la
révélation de la sphère julie gayet
françois hollande
c'est la toute première fois dans
l'histoire que la presse people révéler
un secret présidentielle mais closer
c'est aussi des politiques en maillot
des stars prise la main dans le sac et
laurence a été à la bonne école avant
closer elle a travaillé pour public
france dimanche voici et le figaro
magazine
autant vous dire que question potins
avec elle à la machine à café vous avez
intérêt à prendre un allongé mais ce
soir ce n'est pas la magnat de la presse
people qu'on reçoit puisque laurence
pieau à changer de carrière elle est
aujourd'hui la créatrice du site
alternatif vegan un titre d'information
pour aider à devenir vegan et c'est en
rencontrant le journaliste franz olivier
giesbert qu'elle a ouvert les yeux sur
la maltraitance animale et l'absurdité
de manger autant de viande ce soir
laurence pieau est notre invité dans tpm
people et elle va tout nous dire sur les
coulisses de ces scouts
certainement parce que les gens nous
connaissent et sébastien d'allier la
première peut pas rêver france et le
comment le premier pape à radio france
doit partir avant la fin d'émission le
droit d'un avion pour aller où ah bah ça
je vais pas vous dire et pour faire quoi
je vais pas vulgaire non plus de faire
un shooting a peut-être ils achètent et
qui a on verra c'est la semaine
prochaine il paraît que ça se passe dans
les pays du soleil
oui c'est possible c'est vrai mes
amitiés quand même au maghreb alors les
amis alors à parler de hollande gayet
c'est vous qui avez fait les photos on
sait évidemment le scoop que ça a été
sur le fameux scooter et vous dit
laurence que l' enquête a duré quasiment
un an
comment c'est possible que l'enquêté
durera non ça veut dire que il se voyait
jamais vous n'arrivez jamais à faire en
sorte qu'ils se croisent pendant
l'annoncé de ces deux cas ça c'est qu'on
a on avait commencé à travailler sur
cette affaire et à il ya un an quand la
rumeur courait paris ouais et et on
passe pas un an sur des histoires donc
on a passé quelques semaines à vous
envoyer quelqu'un juste quelques jours
en bas de l'appartement et 6 passes rien
vous avoir tenait enfin oui ça peut être
ça mais on
on enquête aussi on a essayé de recouper
il ya des rumeurs qui sont pas à
vérifier donc à partir du moment où j'ai
des gars y avait publié un communiqué en
disant mais l afp ce qui était quelque
chose assez étonnant en disant non non
on n'est pas ensemble et c'est une
fausse rumeur on s'est dit si elle prend
le risque de démentir c'est qu'elle ne
l'est pas donc on avait décroché comme
votre joueur on avait arrêté de bosser
et puis et puis il ya eu quelques mois
plus tard une séquence au grand journal
qui était assez étonnante sur canal ou
julie gayet étaient présentes ou
l'histoire avec françois hollande a été
ou en tout cas la preuve la présence de
françois hollande sur son film a été un
peu évoquée elle en a rigolé et partant
de ce moment là c'est la vie non on va
on va pouvoir l'envoyer sur cette
histoire j'ai appelé sébastien parce que
je savais que sébastien travailler aussi
reçu c'est sébastien qui a trouvé
l'adresse de la rue du cirque qui ont là
on s'est dit on va bosser dessus et on
va passer par un an mais on va essayer
un mois trois semaines et l'histoire est
arrivé quand même assez zip et vous avez
fait les photos vous étiez le seul à ce
moment là vraiment vraiment sur le coup
oui oui ben vous avez eu de la chance
parce que dit-il paparazzi qui étaient
là jour là d'un huitième nous c'est ça a
été du boulot quand même donc il n'y a
pas eu la chance le coup de chance qu'il
ya eu
vers la fin c'est de trouver l'adresse
et parce que julie gayet était au café
de flore un jour et que j'ai été prévenu
et que je suis allé voir ce qu'elle
faisait gelé suivi j'ai vu une voiture
de la présidence de république arrivé
avec un garde du corps que je
connaissais donc j'ai commencé à me dire
que bon ça s'entend là et c'est parti du
côté de l'arrêt du cirque mais c'est
vrai qu'on y bosse est depuis quasiment
un an
on s'est échangé des informations ont
donc on était au courant de cette
histoire entre eux à un moment
on s'est rapproché un petit peu du coup
parce que elle avait pris quelques
rondeurs donc ça a regardé ce qui se
passait donc voilà et c'est par à coups
en fait parce que on avait toujours un
petit peu un temps de retard pour
trouver l'adresse faible il faut aussi
parfois nous après son arrivée il
n'était plus là à partir du moment où on
a trouvé la rue du cirque ça s'est fait
assez rapidement et laqué sommes
supposés valérie trierweiler qu'à ce
moment là sortez avec françois hollande
elle était au courant de cette d'abord
un de la relation extra conjugale et 2
kg et photos les sortir alors que les
photos allaient sortir non lors de la
relation m'a canton quand on lit merci
pour ce moment on voit bien que des
explications au sein du coup oui mais
c'est après coup j'ai surfé le film avec
anthony cocu autour d'anna informé nom
n'avait elle en avait entendu parler
elle en avait entendu parler quand on
interroge à passer reprise c'est elle
même qui appelle julie gayet en lui
demandant de faire un démenti sur la
place publique elle va grandement merci
donc simplement pour vous c'est l'énorme
coup c'est à dire que les ventes au delà
au delà de la renommée de la renommée du
magazine mais ç'a rapporté beaucoup
d'argent ces photos ça ça rapportait
beaucoup notoriété ça rapporte aussi
beaucoup mal de tête parce que parce
qu'on a été
il ya eu des poursuites y compris des
poursuites pénales de deux valeurs et à
valeur et de julie gayet et de mascate
où le pénal c'était c'était julie gayet
pour les produits non monsieur
non non pour une faute en a produit
autour d'elle dans une voiture dans
paris la voiture étant considéré comme
un domicile privé
il y avait il y avait du pénal dont
comme elles ont touché environ les deux
réunis alors
on valérie trierweiler 54 me au rouge
est julie gayet pas loin la voiture
c'est donc la mélasse cinq ans le
magazine donne cent dix mille euros
comme ça le le groupe le groupe mondial
et paul quilès extincteur vous dis pas
tu as maintenant c'est un peu le rend
bien pour ça que je vous dise et plus
c'est plus de la notoriété parce que ça
a coûté pas moins d'achat alors on a
fait des ventes extraordinaires on a
retiré trois fois le magazine en termes
de en terme de notoriété pour le masi ça
a été formidable et je pense que même en
termes de 2,2 de véracité de sahamies la
presse people
sur un autre plan absolue et totale de
crédibilité au sein du conduit est
vraiment vraiment garder des enfants
voilà par deux secondes juste les
conséquences pour vous savez quoi il
l'un et l'autre toi je crois que c'est
un contrôle fiscal
bah on s'est retrouvés tous les deux
avec la même lettre
non non au pénal n'ont ils jamais dit
non non on était ensemble assez pénible
d'ailleurs on avait passé cinq heures à
être interrogé comme si on était des
délinquants s'est dit d'accord et après
willy un contrôle fiscal mais même moi
la contrôleuse m'a bien confirmé que les
ordres venaient de là haut et que
c'était suite à ça donc à ouidah de
représailles a pas de menace pour ce
courrier vont c'est pas de corbeaux il
n'y a pas une menace il ya eu
effectivement un petit contrôle fiscal
comme comme sébastien il ya eu je pense
françois hollande a dit je ne signerai
pas parce que je suis présent de la
république donc donc je n'ai pas à
signer en revanche il ya une réforme des
aides à la presse qu' qui a touché la
trêve d'intérêt général et je pense
qu'elle n'était pas enfin voilà qu'on
n'était pas totalement inouï là toute
l'histoire
moi je suis frappée parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle a redoré le blason de la presse
people
parce que cette information est
importante il fait une année fort
pendant le débat et sans prétention est
en moi président je serais irréprochable
pouf il ya une info qui sont il n'est
pas revu le plus beau c'est parfaitement
cohérent et elle a le courage que n'a
pas eue les quais les migrants les mags
les grands magazines dits de la france
en général qui ne sortent rien soit le
privé et c'était assez pas bien pardon
ce qui était assez drôle c'est que on
avait vent sorti des années sarkozy où
il y avait quand même beaucoup de choses
car là ça absolument en dessous et quand
on a vu arriver france irlande ont
saigné doit se chercher cinq ans à
cabrera ordinaire
vous savez toujours se méfier des gens
qui disent en toute honnêteté moi je
transparent moi je suis voilà ce qui
calme le plus quelque chose en général
son inverse on va paraître philippot
florian philippot vous sait qu est ce qu
a travaillé dessus c'est vous qui a fait
les peler photo ça même si c'était moi
je peux difficilement vous le dire bien
sûr aux risqueraient des problèmes bien
sûr et puis d alors dans son cas
clairement montceau florian philippot à
l'époque passait beaucoup beaucoup la
télévision et là c'est à vienne avec son
camarade et vous pensez ce que vous
dites
allez le shooter lui en pensant qui sera
en coupe et ce serait le femme vous
tombez sur un homme
et là vous sortez quand même
l'information ou clairement c'est ce
qu'on appelle de la outings c'est à dire
que vous vous dites qu'une personne est
homosexuel alors qu'elle ne l'a pas
révélé est-ce que après coup là au delà
de du fait qu'ils soient front national
si vous n'aimez pas au-delà du fait ça
donne politique et que c'est un coup est
ce qu'après coup vous n'avez pas des
regrets alors pas du tout non vraiment
pas du tout il faudra parce que
effectivement quand on sait quand on
s'est intéressé à florian philippot il
était extrêmement présent donc d'étaler
un peu fouillé dans ce qui était sa vie
ce qui était ce personnage qui arrivé
comme ça très vite et puis on est tombé
sur un compagnon est pas une compagne
par fond de là au moment du mariage pour
tous
est ce qu'on doit s'interdire parce
qu'on tombe sur effectivement une maison
homosexuels n'est pas niée sont
hétérosexuels de terre cette histoire
nous on a pris le parti de dire voilà un
couple homo et yale un couple hétéro et
il n'ya pas faim n'y a pas de
différenciation à faire on va pas sympa
lors duquel nous aso pour guillaume
n'est ce pas alors non mais y ait eu
beaucoup de débats
en réponse de laurence hahn hon non
parce que les homosexuels
nous on moi c'est ce que je retiens de
cette histoire circulaient les
journalistes hétéro ou condamner
absolument dans leur grande unanimité
c'était impossible d'argumenter à
l'époque et on a eu les journées celle
gbt derrière nous je pense notamment à
un éditorial du directeur de têtu
village où beauté parce qu'il a eu la
joie vous avez vous avez une réponse qui
est vraiment tout péter de ça dit mais
pardon vous n'a jamais vu de personnes
hétérosexuelles agressé dans la rue pour
hétérophobie on n'a jamais eu de
personnes hétérosexuelles même mise à
l'écart de ça paye parce qu'il annonce à
sa famille qu'il était la communauté on
n'a jamais vécu cela
homosexuel dans sa dent dans sa grande
majorité nous a soutenu et voté oui ont
dit que c'était bien qu'il n'ya pas de
différence si vous aviez fait les
poteaux si vous avez fait les photos est
ce que vous vous auriez été pour qu'elle
soit publiée évidemment non mais on ne
s'est pas les rues et vous le savez
qu'il n'ait pu aider avec et des
personnes qui se veut également écartés
de leur famille qui devait être intégrée
c'est dans la rue il est personne qui le
vivent mal les patients qui se suicida
barreaux comme atlas extrême malgré
d'abord la personne qui accompagne et
florian philippot après je vous laisse
parler pardon la personne qui accompagne
et furent un filippo été complètement
foot et oui elle était méconnue on parle
de lui la wii non mais autant à l'aller
mais ça a expliqué au moment du fallu
elle il y avait il y avait eu une
incidence politique au fait que florian
philippot avait une influence sur les
positions de marine le pen baquet du
monde raphaëlle bacqué du monde a dit
que vos armes a ouvert la porte et m'a
permis avec cette histoire de traiter de
l' influence du du non halal alors je
vous dire que la toile avait eu droit
qu'aux j'ai dit que vous savez qu'on
peut être aussi homosexuel et être
contre le mariage pour tous ça va ça
d'après les mêmes droits mais on a les
mêmes droits qu'un hétéro alors moi je
veux pas la seule raison pour laquelle
vous avez été soutenue par les de
l'association lgbt c'est parce qu'il
venait du front national avait été à
monsieur socialiste d'accord et emilien
jamais les réactions arrêter les mêmes
premièrement deuxième manche lui même
dit que c'est parce qu'il était en
national que vous l'aviez sortir la
deuxième chose dès que j'entends bien si
on parlait de françois hollande très
bien vous avez fait un énorme carton
énorme scoop sauf que moi ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'à partir de ce moment là vous
avez cru vous faisiez de l'information
surtout n'est encore non non vous faites
pas la formation fait noir avec françois
hollande et ces affaires là ça
représente 1 % des cas traités dans les
magazines people le reste du temps ce
sont les meneurs de savatan de
s'éclairer et mathieu d'information fait
un sens pour la bonne raison que ça
explique en partie la position défendue
mémo nationale au moment du mariage pour
tous le seul que marie louise est des
trêves on est très heureux donner et non
pas manifesté pourquoi parce qu'il est
florent philippot est homosexuel et vous
l'avez a ôté parce que ça fait un sens
pour moi ça fait un certain temps les
informations aucun 10 ans a ôté
quelqu'un catherine qu'ils aient pris
une balle dans la tête moderne avait été
rejeté par sa famille n'y avait plus
personne à part des soirées dans un
avion ça explique ça explique son
comportement public j'ai ya d'autres
impôts li ya alors victime en revanche
aider parce que le sujet avait aussi
pour but de sébastien mais qui paraît il
ya d'autres hommes politiques
homosexuels ouais vous ne votez pas pour
autant absolument nationale à la limite
de la presse people séquence boucau
quand vous commencez à faire de la
politique avec des avis et que tout d'un
coup vous pourrez décider de temps en
temps on est au courant de choses mais
on n'a pas les photos donc on va pas le
sortir aller par un choix politique de
se dire on va on va pas sortir cette
photo d'un homme politique parce qu'il
est les républicains et socialistes ont
voulu parce qu'il est front national
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas les images
c'est tout alors aucun lien on y
reviendra mais c'est parce que je
profitais de sébastien ans qu'ils s'en
aillent aucun lien mais j'avoue qu'on
parle de françois fillon ou françois
fillon il était donc aux primaires y
passe les primaires après toutes les
histoires et du coup y perd au premier
tour des élections présidentielles mais
voilà j'ai ouï dire que à cette époque
vous suiviez ou alors on peut le dire
sébastien pardon vous suiviez faribault
certaine nos confrères la suivait
françois fillon pour éventuellement
sortir un scoop au niveau du du premier
tour c'était quoi ce scoop
ah bah si c'était une histoire de 2 2 et
6 2 couples des histoires de couples des
histoires de couple à la voilà oui ils
se disaient ils se disent eh bien non
mais on additionnait l' amitié avec
conformité que tu en voilà il se disait
que
il y avait des photos à faire virtuel
d'histoires de couples concernant
monsieur film voilà très bien ça vous
étiez au courant
c'est dans ces cas là c'est vous qui
commandite et qu'une chose pareille
parce que voulait faire un coup
peut-être avec l'odeur c'était voilà
vous y étiez au courant de ça ou pas du
tout non mais on comment dit-on
commandite rien travaillons très bien
sûr quelque chose on enquête on recouvre
et si on a une piste on essaie de faire
des images civam à capturer des pièces
que vous aviez un dossier sur françois
fillon qui est jamais sorti parce que le
premier tour premier tour il a perdu
maintenant d'ailleurs on a sorti nice
fort la veille du premier tour sont
françois fillon absolument rien donc on
a sorti ce qu'on avait voila voila vais
rien d'heureux donc y en a qui avait plu
chartier mais c'est pas sorti si on
avait dit non ce que prévu n'ont jamais
je ne dirai rien mais vous m'aviez dit
vous m'aviez dit
bassil et s il avait passé le premier
tour je pense qu'on avait un accord
les photos si on les avait elle serait
sortie c'est pas le problème maintenant
évidemment s'il avait passé le premier
tour on aurait continué à parler de lui
donc peut-être que donc arrêté près de
dix ans alors c'est vrai que maintenant
ça intéresse beaucoup moins oui mais ça
c'est sur cela que je m'embête pas avec
vol ah c'est vrai tu t'en veux tendre
affirmé jim au moins nous attend quand
même
diana ross qui est là tu t'en vas alors
qu'elle est là bon c'est un peu la faute
aussi être juste c'est un acteur une
actrice un artiste mais laurent ça ne
m'intéresse plus parce que maintenant
elle s'occupe de jean vegan et la
patience à ses bras par les hommes que
je vais suivre et vegan non voilà cette
merde acteurs actrices à travailler
ensemble alors acteurs actrices acteurs
actrices abba quelque chose dans le
genre acteurs à chercher chez vous un
licencié en mode écran
non je n'ai gardé si vous regardez vous
êtes au maghreb
vous êtes acteur ou actrice vous êtes
vegan barré cadets vous permet tout
l'homme de longueuil débarque
je pense qu'il va me détester on va
inventer du coup un petit peu oui pardon
non joly c'est à dire par rapport à ce
tracé un peu parce qu'il était là on
veut peut-être tout ça a été intéressant
d'avoir ces images c'est à parle des
coupes comme il a une position une
posture politique extrêmement moral et
moralisatrice et vieilles familles et
tous à apporter une information dont on
raconte la vie d'un dirigeant n'est pas
conforme avec ce nom maintenant quand tu
dis quoi que ce soit fabriqué un
règlement de comptes
moi je rêve mais avant la scission du
tout l'esprit parfois vous avez eu un
problème de conscience
quand même des prix globalement en 14
ans est-ce que vous avez au mot pour
nous dire un article ou une que vous
regrettez en 14 ans ça peut arriver on
fait tous des erreurs
alors y en a une ouais il y en a une que
je regrette je regrette pas parce que je
regarde c'est qu'elle a été mal comprise
donc ça veut dire qu'elle est et voilà
qu'elle était mal fait que je lé mal
faite au monde arrivait de carla bruni
dans la vie nicolas sarkozy on a publié
une photo de carla bruni en monobike
photos de cécilia sarkozy en maillot de
bain et elle était mis sur un même plan
et et en fait on voulait raconter une
femme qui partait d'arrivée et c est ça
n'a pas du tout été compris comme ça ça
a été juste perçu comme un comparatif
physique alors qu'il n'était pas une
voie là d'accord quelqu'un qui avait dix
ans de moins et est là pour un journal
féminin ouais je pense que c'est une
vraie erreur donc oui ça je regrette
et justement parlons de sa de nicolas
sarkozy et carla bruni voilà vous dit
que c'est une personne vous avez
photographié à disney et j'ai je vous ai
entendu dire que c'est une personne qui
se baladait à disney donc une personne
lambda qui a téléphoné à la rédaction de
closer en disant il ya sarko et carla
qui sont là vous pouvez bien c'est vrai
alors c'est pas une personne qui est
valable à distance c'est une personne
qui avaient l'info une semaine avant une
lectrice en fait qu'appeler les créa une
lectrice qui a appelé parce qu'elles
avaient elles avaient eu cette
information s'est récemment c'est le
lecteur qui vous appelle comme ça ça
arrive mais une information de cette
importance non donc ça nous a paru
complètement dingue je les sens qu'ils
aillent qu'ils aillent qu'ils aillent à
disney pour une probable sortie
mais que c'était un truc juste fou et
donc on a là aussi on a essayé de
recouper et puis on nous a dit que
c'était plausible effectivement qu'ils
aillent se montrait ce moment là que ce
qui m'intéresse laurence et que vous
avez dit dans une interview vous avez
dit nous - grâce à la presse people on
les montre comme ils sont et on tombe
pas grosso modo dans les galas et tout
est posé avec une voix là on tombe pas
justement dans le côté ils maîtrisent
totalement leur comme nous on n'est pas
dans leurs coffres patients sauf que là
vous doutez bien que nicolas sarkozy et
carla bruni en plein milieu disney
devant tout le monde savait très bien
que vous allez dès que vous allez venir
et les shoots et donc là quelque part
vous êtes tombé dans le cours de l'or
comme à eux non quelque part ils font de
la com et leur maîtrise alors non parce
que quand quand les vous savez quand on
sort ce genre d'histoires ya toujours
des gens qui qui n'était pas la joie des
commentateurs politiques notamment qui
disent on est moi je vais vous expliquer
comment ça s'est passé
moi je vais vous expliquer parce que ce
week end de folie ça a été mon premier
gros week-end de noël donc je me
rappelle très bien de politique people
et et en fait on entend dire aujourd'hui
que sarkozy et carla bruni ont convoqué
les journalistes et les photographes
s'il avait convoqué les photographes il
aurait été deux sens il n'aurait pas été
sain qu'il y avait cinq photographes y
en avait quatre de closer et un
cinquième qui est arrivé un peu par
accident
donc je pense que carla bruni elle a
très bien résumé le truc elle a dit on
ne se montre pas mais on ne se cache pas
non plus ils sont arrivés à cinq heures
du soir quand la nuit tombe et à disney
effectivement ils ne se sont pas cachés
mais moi cinq heures du soir même et
photographes étaient là depuis 9 heures
du matin et je leur ai dit il faut
décrocher et ils ont vu une voiture un
convoi à partir de chez carla bruni en
direction de disney l'on dise à temps il
ya un truc qui bouge on va quand même
attendre
il jouera tendu et on a bien fait
d'attendre puisque on a eu les images et
les photos mais ils ont pas enfin on n'a
pas été on n'a pas été l'instrument
d'une comme pour en revenir à ce que
vous disiez et à ce rôle d'information
je maintiens que fait la presse people
qui a fait la presse people et qui et
j'espère le fera encore longtemps le le
le je fais ce que je veux dire à ses
programmes et non mais c'est malgré tout
quand je dis que ce n'est pas de
l'information jeu juste rappeler qu'il
ya un truc sur la protection de la vie
privée
alors ans parce que le magazine closer a
fait énormément de bien à la presse mais
bien ce pour la première fois on fait
souvent l'opposition entre les
journalistes people qui sont les mauvais
journalistes et les journalistes de la
presse waouh génial le monde le figaro
etc
je suis désolé histoire de hollande
égailler ça fait tous les titres ils ont
fait des ventes records toute cette
presse qu'elle avance au sérieux mais ça
m'arrive quand j'amène faut arrêter dit
souhaiter gayet ou de sarkozy ces deux
cas sur des gens met en avant sa mort
plein de questions et pas beaucoup de
temps ce n'est pas l'histoire du titre
l'implication de dsk dans la sphère du
carlton
quatre sorties causeur.fr me dites pas
que c'est pas la faute des hommes et oui
mais c'est une minorité des choses que
vous traitez alors un bon ça va très
vite en revenir
pour en revenir à la retrouver mon idée
sur la véracité moi je pense que les
photos paparazzi
la véritable info les photos vrai elles
sont là la vérité elle est dans les
photos de l'instant et pas dans les
photos makaya coiffeur on pourrait très
bien est ce que ça vous arrive que là
c'est une personne qui appelle réaction
excuses vous ça vous arrive pas dans ce
soit des people eux mêmes ou des gens
qui balancent un petit peu sur leurs
petits camarades pour que vous allez
suivre sortir quelque chose
alors non très peu je pense que quand
ils veulent balance et je pense qu'ils
s'arrangent un peu plus intelligemment
pour des joueurs alors passer quelqu'un
d'autre part quel hôtel un mécano me
voilà il nous est arrivé une fois
une fois d'avoir de la rue au téléphone
non jean luc delarue jean luc delarue
quant au moment où au moment où il
allait annoncer son cancer et il pensait
qu'on avait l'info oui on avait l'info
il pensait qu'on allait sortir non on
avait décidé de ne pas le sortir
d'accord et il nous a dit voilà moi je
vais en parler donc autant travailler
avec vous on va faire les papiers collés
ensemble et on voit et on a fait on a
fait plusieurs ce que j'avais écrit très
bien avant qu'on va se terrer gym des
stars pas ça m'intéresse d'avoir traduit
aussi quelques questions très très très
rapide juste vous répondez comme ça oui
nous rapidement calé people qui est le
plus touché en 14 ans force de faire des
procès des procédés procès qui unit for
abba long de l'arête on me dit on s'en
fout du régime des stars bravo bravo
bravo la semaine prochaine on vise tout
en direct très bien très bien
ah bah on me dit non c'est trop
intéressant et florence on fera le
régime des stars la semaine prochaine
ce en mettant ce que guillaume était à
fond sur ce sujet
comme beaucoup de personnes mais vous
vous avez déjà perdu nous fait un régime
draconien depuis quinze jours et vous
avez déjà perdu manqué sont très fiers
de vous quel est quel est le people
qu'elle plus touchés selon vous l'un ou
les people peut-être mais je pense que
jennifer beaucoup hein
jennifer oui on avait parlé aussi voulu
céder santé des médailles puis à la kate
middleton et ça leur part dans le
capital effectivement la fameuse kate
middleton effectivement aulas vous
faites les poteaux dans closer et là
c'est un raz de marée sa part partout je
crois que c'était aussi l'une des plus
grosses condamnation en termes d'argent
ouais ça c'était quoi bien cinquante
mille euros
cent cinquante mille euros et 50000
euros personnel 650 millions combien
personnel 50 ans tout ça fait combien on
m'avait dit cent cinquante mille 50
minéraux et la l'ac milan pardon 150 et
45 ça fait 195 milles euros
oui hélas hélas là et là j'aimerais
comprendre en quoi une fois une
princesse ou une balade à ma future
reine la future rue la future reine mais
d'un pays qui n'est pas le nôtre peut
toucher dix fois plus que ddd people
français qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
comme closer à la base la maison mère
c'est l'odeur anglais est ce que pour
vous des ya eu des répercussions
importantes sur le closer français oui
parce qu'on affaiblit le port anglais
qui n'avaient rien à voir avec
l'histoire cvuh bombardé comme ça un
matin deux coups de pied de menacer des
abonnements de il comprenait pas ce qui
leur arrive et donc il ya une grosse
colère effectivement dû éditeur du close
avant avait en disant bon bah on va vous
enlevez la licence donc clairement ça
veut dire qu'on pouvait plus appeler
closer du tout donc industriellement
c'était un peu chaud et puis et puis il
ya eu quelque chose que moi en tout
lesquels j'ai pas mesuré du tout c'est
le statut d'icône le kate middleton
frère elle venait elle venait d'épouser
williams est en fait on touchait ont
touché à la sacrée reine sacré et si
vous aviez su après coup qui aurait deux
cent mille euros de 2,2 d'amande
est-ce que vous l'auriez quand même fait
malgré tout parce que c'était un très
gros coup de fer là là plutôt
franchement là très franchement la
décision nous
ne m'appartenait pas vraiment à c'était
une décision de l'éditeur après les
fausses paparazzades existe encore ou
pas qu'on explique aux gens c'est le
paparazzi qui se met encore un accord
avec un people et puis ensuite on vend
des photos ça existe encore ça alors
exister un bas ça fait partie des choses
qu'on répète je pense que quand s'il ya
une fois savoir avalant tout lesquels il
a le le rédacteur en chef d'op est
dedans c'est d'accord c'est à dire que
c'est un mec vous n'êtes pas au courant
vous même bah c'est à dire que je pense
peut-être qui en a vu mais moi j'étais
pas au courant en tous les cas on ferait
pas je pense qu'une fausse paparazzade
déjà quand elle se fait savoir ouais on
voit sur les images et qu' on n'est pas
là pour servir les stars on est là pour
servir le lecteur donc c'est surtout
dans public allemand non non je
plaisante je plaisante
nantes est en hausse et qui a fermé
c'était au pardon miria moi j'aime faire
insulte en corner enroulé c'est pas du
tout public sous un beau et puis après
je me revient seul à faire kate et
william je travaille dans le même groupe
que laurence à l'époque gers magazine
c'est la seule fois où j'ai vu des
policiers gardaient l'entrée de
l'immeuble où était l'hôte et le
magazine y avait des gens devant fin ça
a été très très chaud pourrait j'imagine
ce que ça faisait devant c'était
l'émeute
est-ce que vous avez des impôts
dernières questions d info vous avez des
infos en 14 ans évidemment que vous
n'avez jamais sorti qu'aurait pu faire
vriller vrille et la france
voilà en fait c'est un homme politique
bah voilà vous êtes une femme plein
d'infos vous dire beaucoup d'amis que
d'ennemis
très franchement non on va voir faire
maintenant non je fais je pense que les
histoires qu'on n'a pas sortir c'est
principalement les histoires sur
lesquels pour lesquels on n'avait pas
d'image
ouais parce que dans la presse people
sans photo p d'histoire batterie et puis
il ya quelques efforts mais assez peu
con c'est interdit de sortir oui parce
que voilà est d'accord et alors
aujourd'hui vous changez tout autour pas
raconter pourquoi vous partez après 15
ans parce que le groupe ait racheté par
un autre groupe justement le magazine et
jeudis vous faite vous êtes complètement
autre chose vous monter un site vegan
ouais c'est quoi c'est par ici le
mediapart vegan c'est en fait de façon
très présente très très prétentieux je
vous réfère le mediapart de la malbouffe
ouais c'est à dire expliqué
effectivement il ya un site qui
s'appelle alternative et gagnent points
comme je suis en train de créer une
structure de recruter une équipe pour
pour faire un média en fait sur le
sur le sur le véganisme qui n'est pas un
blog
ouais rien n'est pas un méga niveau sans
fond l'entente en france lire avait
gagné beaucoup plus mesurée n'ont exclu
en tolérant expliquer en quoi en
changeant une seule chose votre
alimentation pouvait changer
plein de choses d'accord un impact sur
votre santé sur la souffrance animale
sur l'environnement aussi donc je vais
l'interviewer il ya des médecins qui
vont intervenir jeu mais il va tout va
le faire des emplettes pardon ça s'est
ouvert il est au même site elle est
ouverte à il est ouvert d inscrire à la
newsletter il ya un magazine qui qui qui
devrait re catherine d'inscrits est en
fait l'idée c'est de faire parce que je
sais faire ce que j'ai fait dans people
c'est à dire d'aller enquêter d'aller
gratter d'aller peut-être un peu
dérangée et mais de le faire sur sur
l'alimentaire et d'aller de m'attaquer à
votre personne et d'exercer mon métier
dans un bol et élise lucet de la
malbouffe
on va voir un petit peu ça on va essayer
en tout cas je peux vous dire j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'admiration
respect pour vous un grande femme
d'affaires et je pense que vous je pense
que vous réussirez vraiment pas ce que
ça vous dit quelque chose je réussis